this video is sponsored by scentbird
stay tuned for more info later in the
video hello everyone today i wanted to
catch up on a couple of new stories
starting with battlefield 2042
removing a mode entirely and kind of the
journey that this game has gone through
which has been kind of nuts to watch
before we get into it i did want to
remind you that i just started a brand
new channel i'll leave a link in the
description it contains all content that
doesn't have to do with video games
movies and tv all of my like
entertainment stuff content will all go
here but several of my podcasts are
moving any kind of personal content
vlogs personal q a's are all going to
the new channel so i'm just going to
remind you for a little bit so people
don't wonder where idiots and abroad
went okay so we're on pc gamer right now
and first up dice is removing
battlefield 2042's 128 player
breakthrough playlist says 64 players is
more tactical
uh but apparently the 128 player
conquest playlist isn't going anywhere
it sets let me make myself smaller maybe
i'll move myself over here that makes it
easier i don't need to be smaller
and we can probably zoom in a little bit
all right look at us go
um so obviously in case you missed it
battlefield 2042
i was unbelievably excited about it when
it was announced like one of my most
anticipated games of the year um
for a lot of reasons but
a lot of people felt the same way i
definitely wasn't alone in that and then
early impressions of the beta
were pretty negative um there was a
story about one guy like
literally caught his pc on fire i don't
know that that's really ea battlefield's
fault maybe more of a hardware shoot but
it's still very funny um very buggy and
you know a lot of i guess fans were like
no it'll be fine just wait till it comes
out but unfortunately battlefield has
not had a particularly long
history of um things being
great on launch and so when it did come
out it was still very buggy on launch i
actually
know some people who work at ea and
there was a period with
battlefield 4 i believe that they had
this board that had each of the levels
in that game or each of the maps i
couldn't tell you exactly um and they
were ranked they had color rankings
based on how functional they were and
red was like completely broken yellow
was like some bug fixes and green was
like good to ship uh majority of them
were in red and never shifted into
yellow and they shipped the game anyway
um
that is anecdotal from somebody i know
who worked there i have no guarantee
that that's true i won't always want to
clarify that whenever i report on
something like this second hand have not
seen it myself cannot promise you that
that is true in any case
that's what i heard
uh so
battlefield 2042 came out has been buggy
has not been received very well and um
the hype has died um i have not played
it since launch
and so it makes sense that a lot of
changes have rolled through the article
goes on to say after the next
battlefield 2042 update drops on
thursday morning players will no longer
be able to queue for the 128 player
breakthrough matches there'll still be a
128 player conquest playlist the main
battlefield game mode in that it's the
original but developer dice has decided
that breakthrough is more fun without
battlefield 2042's double to play
account it's a very interesting
take it's time to talk about scentbird
these came from new york and i actually
recently just took them to new york
because they are
perfect travel sized perfumes so if you
haven't heard of scentbird it is a
subscription-based perfume service and
they sent me transcendent by catherine
melandrino daisy love by marc jacobs
prada
by prada
i think that's the first prada product
i've ever owned in my life and this one
smells amazing this is my favorite scent
it's delicious it's very common for
australians and i think europeans as
well to wear perfumes and colognes um
and when i moved to the us i kind of
stopped doing it as much people in
america just don't smell as good so a
very nice thing about scentbird is that
they have gotten me back on that train i
am experimenting with different smells
and wearing them more often they are the
perfect place to begin if you've never
tried any perfumes or scents at all you
can discover a style that you like build
a collection and express your
individuality through very fancy
fragrances for nowhere near as much as
you would think they would cost
scentbird lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
receive so there are no surprises and
with each fragrance you get a 30 day
supply so you can try it out for 30 days
see if you like it before you commit to
buying a whole bottle which some of
these are worth like hundreds of dollars
and you get them for almost nothing so
if you want to start smelling amazing
use my coupon code alana p55 for 55
off at scentbird that is just seven
dollars for your first month which is so
cool and it is available in the usa and
canada thanks to stanford for sponsoring
the video i'm a really big fan now back
to the video
the chaos of 128 player maps was one of
the many criticism players leveled at
battlefield 2042 when it launched which
i would definitely agree with it is a
lot um dice says that after giving it
some thought it agrees that the
importance of individual squads and
players is reduced due to the increased
intensity and chaos of the combat in 128
player breakthrough and i thought this
was interesting
because
i agree with that criticism that it was
overwhelming
but
i think the fault there
um from dice is actually
that they didn't balance the maps
appropriately for that volume of players
less that that amount of players no
matter what is just too chaotic oh we
didn't know that this many players would
be chaotic it's
much more that they the maps weren't
balanced for that amount of players and
that's why it feels chaotic you can
absolutely have 128 players conquest
still has it obviously um
but when
the game isn't built for it it kind of
was never
going to work and it's surprising to me
that they didn't realize that in play
testing uh in any case breakthrough is
an attack and defend mode in which one
team must capture a series of sectors in
order creating a somewhat defined front
line conquest on the other hand puts all
the map's capture points up for grabs at
the same time and is categorized by many
independent skimmishes on going on all
at once and my guess
is that
it was balanced for conquest and just
not balanced for um breakthrough
they just thought it would work i don't
know
uh when reviewing breakthrough we noted
that the 64 player version represented a
more tactical experience which i don't
doubt
reducing our play account here helps to
remove some of the chaos from the
experience and in combination with the
reductions that we may have made to the
number of available combat vehicles it
means players are better able to hold
front lines more effectively
players will also find more space to
work together and fulfill their
individual roles i think this is a good
call ultimately but it does seem
nuts that this had to happen and that it
happened this far after launch is what
gets me it seems so surprising that
this wasn't figured out earlier that it
wasn't catered to earlier or potentially
it seemed like and this isn't how game
development works but it seemed like
nice marketing you know like that it was
like 128 player modes we got loads of
them how cool
without really
thinking of the long game of uh how odd
that might be to play it's a little more
context from ign here
uh yeah announcer would be reading
battlefield 2042 is 128 play
breakthrough multiplayer mode on
playstation xbox series and pc
uh we'll stick to the 64 play account
version and this is happening may 19
uh ea on its website let's just go there
they said
a little bit
4.1 no pets
update 4.1 releases on may 19. the focus
for this update is to deliver further
fixes the quality of life improvements
as well as to update our all-out warfare
rotations alongside some balance changes
to weapons and specialists summary key
changes the overall power of boris's
sg36 sentry gun has been reduced which
fair angel can no longer provide armor
plates fire his supply back stop work
stock weapons now handle better through
improved base recoil to compensate we've
slightly reduced the recoil benefits
provided by attachments that's
interesting
all that warfare playlists have been
updated with new setups removing
breakthrough 128 128
from the list of options
uh up next now update schedule is the
release of season one
currently set for release in early june
i like that they say currently set maybe
that's the solution to the the constant
um
delay conversations we're having right
now maybe people should start saying
currently set to release rather than is
releasing
we'll be back with a full overview and
update uh notes closer to release
so your ea notes play account was
reduced to felt like each player's
individual contributions were reduced
due to the sheer intensity and chaos
during co and it is intense like
especially if you watch people stream it
even good players like i'm okay at
battlefield
you watch good players it it is uh
even for them it looks like it's too
chaotic to handle
um
so we've been over all of this this is
kind of what i wanted to touch on is a
little bit more of the context here so
battlefield 2042 hasn't had the best
time in the spotlight it was late with
features such as adding a scoreboard and
voice chat functionality which does seem
nuts at one point it even had fewer
concurrent players on steam than
previous entries in the franchise
that is wild
ea reportedly also blamed the timing of
halo infinite surprise multiplayer
release on battlefield 2042's troubles
i could see that
being a thing
um this is from february i missed this
ea admits to battlefield 2042 failed to
meet player expectations blames halo
infinite and covet
did not reflect correctly reflect the
tone of the meaning okay well worth
going into this that uh es
communications vp said these stories are
not accurately capturing the discussion
in the context so note that
original story is as follows ea has
reportedly admitted that battlefield
2042 failed to meet the expectations of
our players in an internal meeting and
blamed the failure of the game on
factors such as halo infinite's launch
and the ongoing covert pandemic
according to a report by xfire ea held
an internal company-wide meeting to
discuss battlefield 2042 where
executives spent over 20 minutes
examining what went wrong with the
game's launch and honestly
it's kind of the point that i wanted to
touch on
i will have mentioned it across the
channel a lot but i don't currently talk
about it because i'm not like a current
battlefield player but i love
battlefield um battlefield vietnam in
1942 were the two first games that i
ever played online um i'm a huge bad
company fan i would love to see more bad
company and there have been entries that
i haven't liked very much or that i
haven't played very much of um have
always been a pc player where
battlefield is concerned
um
that i was so hyped for 2042 because it
brought back a lot of the nostalgia that
i had been missing on previous entries
when i kind of stopped playing
battlefield
and the fact that i was that hyped and
that i fell off as fast as i did is so
surprising to me that like i guess part
of it's that it's social so if none of
my friends wanted to play because of the
issues then i didn't have people to play
with um and i was less likely to play a
competitive multiplayer game by myself
but
everything was set up for me to
absolutely fall in love
and i played for maybe a week um
which is just nuts
uh chief studios officer laura mealy
my myell oh sorry laura reportedly
emphasized that it's important to
acknowledge when the company has misses
including battlefield 2042.
when do ign gave it
what a great game what a great game
uh one of the factors that
she apparently mentioned was responsible
for battlefield 2042's problems is the
frostbite engine which had to undergo a
massive update this update reportedly
sucked up 18 months of development time
all new tech it was basically a new
engine the report quotes her as singing
they went back the frostbite version
they were on was so old they had to go
back and update so it's basically
putting the game on a new engine
that shouldn't
you should have they should have known
that ahead of time that's a project
management uh fail
um they also apparently spoke about the
work from home environment as a result
of code 19 that impacted the development
cycle midway through and it does
especially midway through that would
have been
very difficult especially for an online
service game it
it does it totally does that people
aren't lying this isn't an excuse
uh she reportedly said add up all of
this new innovation all of this ambition
for the new project and then you add a
global pandemic halfway into the project
where the game teams had to work from
home we ended up with more new variables
in development than we ever experienced
before and they do deserve the slack for
that nobody knew what to do
however the report says that they also
claimed the surprise launch of halo
infinite's multiplayer was a turning
point which came in here four days
earlier than battlefield 2042's release
on november 19. compared to halo
infinite battlefield 2042 wasn't as
polished so ea reportedly believes
players had a more favorable view of the
former
i would think that that is true too
uh the report also states that
they explained
player expectations have changed and it
wasn't the right choice to retain the
company's previous standards oof that's
interesting they apparently admitted
that ea didn't go wide enough with
different player segments and didn't go
deep enough with the game the lack of
features such as scoreboards and uh voip
systems didn't help either which is true
it seems so nice that they launched
without that
at the end of the call it was reportedly
mentioned that battlefield's development
teams will be restructured and more
streamlined the new surrounding
battlefield 2042 hasn't been great that
is true
um in ign's battlefield 2042 review they
said for a game claiming to be the
future of battlefield 2042's impressive
portal options make it clear that it
doesn't stack up to the past
fair
instead it's the same customization
tools that could come to define it in
time and that customization stuff is
very very cool
um
yeah just just to me uh uh
something i was really excited about
that really just fell off very fast
which is such a shame
um obviously they're actively working on
it but i
am just the absolute removal
um
of a mode
i mean they still have the 64 play
account version
it's just such a surprising like
addition to this whole
thing i don't know thanks again to
scentbird for sponsoring this video
check out the links below